aller mater regarde tous ces gens c'est
fou ça va le public oui les lycées mis
dedans excusez moi je croyais c'est ça
oui c'est vrai il parle de vous comme
d'habitude par les deux secondes séries
j'ai remarqué que tu faisais des trucs
sympa surtout quand je suis pas là
vendredi vous êtes vous êtes régalés
sans moi c'est vrai que les insectes
si c'est des verts au curry exactement
et vert au curry les crises l'écurie des
verts au curry les petits l'incorrection
curie way son très bon parce que vous
dirigez les verts allemands genève est
en fait très bon alors visiblement
poursuivi les verts cédait même sa
prochaine fois quand vous mangerez des
mouches au nutella vous m'appelez
j'avais aussi reçu un ancien membre de
boys band qui est toujours aussi beau je
suis un gars tu
c'est la première fois pour moi
[Musique]
passe
[Applaudissements]
mon magnifique chanson dans laquelle on
s'adresse à une contrôleuse sncf
cyril il ya 40 ans l'homme de gauche
arriver au pouvoir françois mitterrand
quarante ans après la gauche va mal même
très mal d'ailleurs regardez cette photo
voilà à votre avis lequel de ces deux
individus et le plus en voie
d'extinction socialiste ou un panda il
ya 40 ans mitterrandie saison de bottes
d'accord en temps mitterrand libérer les
ondes il a permis d'élargir la liberté
d'expression et du coût 40 ans après il
a permis des débats comme peut-on élire
un clown comme président en arrêt pour
moi la réponse est oui vu le cirque
politique du moment et comme d'habitude
la question est revenue est à votre avis
la question a bien d'où des premiers de
la classe de g vous voulez joindre à
tout un bon je voulais vous demander si
un grand mouvement populaire se lève
pour prolonger ce que dit delphine en
début de l'année prochaine un mouvement
populaire se lève et tous les gens à qui
vous donnez la parole régulièrement
il vous demande vous d'y aller c'est la
tentation du tout une nation c'est
terminé oui mais s'ils oublient pas vous
le demande
malheureusement non je te dis quand vous
en avez convenait pas
alors une fois pour toutes cyril hanouna
ne va pas présenter se présenter à la
présidentielle pour une raison simple la
présidence à parlant télé en moyenne une
heure tous les trois mois
mais comment voulez vous que si tu
supportes survivre on regarde les
chiffres du temps d'antenne 2 places
emmanuel macron 16h cyril hanouna 16000
[Applaudissements]
recherche cir il m'est cher chroniqueur
le public j'ai décidé de résumer la fin
de la semaine d'une nouvelle manière à
la façon d'un match de foot avec thomas
barbazan
ça s'appelle le multi des complexes
adore ça très fort très fort bonsoir
tout bonsoir à tous bienvenue 8 idée
complexe qu'est ce que le oui qui
décomplexe est assez simple vous allez
voir des gens totalement décomplexée
nous avons décidé de les mettre dans
cette petite pastille pour leur rappeler
qu'ils ont été opérés de la route pour
m'accompagner philippe bonjour fille
libre et bonjour stéphane en effet
écouter la science a réussi à percer les
secrets de l'univers mais percer les
secrets de tp c'est encore une autre
histoire
mais cette partie
[Musique]
puis je suis excité je regarde la
feuille de match aujourd'hui il ya le
sosie d'elvis presley ou d'actrices qui
crie loana un policier nerveux on va
passer une bonne soirée c'est sûr et qui
est capitaine un dénommé kilian est baba
commence à bouger
je veux pas être un charmant qu'il
agresse sexuellement blanche au but un
but contre un dessin animé du joueur
algérien ryad verdez le choix un
déhanché un peu chaloupés il me fait
plaisir moi ouais bah il se balade entre
les polémiques comme ça avec facilité il
me rappelle mais si oui alors mais en
fait le prince charmant là il lui grimpe
pas dessus à la blanche-neige enfin
l'emmerdement vécu la butte mais c'est
pas évident c'est une frappe qui part
dans les tribunes ça n'avait aucun sens
ça peut arriver ça peut arriver on peut
passer à côté de son bac ça arrive ça me
rappelle à mon état aulas faut furieux
qui rentre sur le terrain on regarde à
stryker
vous voyez qu'une garde à vue ça peut
être quelqu'un c'est un homme nouveau
c'est vrai pour o2 certains c'est le
gingembre pétrole a triplé d'un policier
il a très bien choisi son pseudo ton ami
c'est pas le verlan de mythos cdc moi
moi j'ai travaillé
comment sur les victimes de violences
sexuelles elles ont pas du tout ce
comportement
c'est à dire que quand on a été violée
je peux vous dire qu'on se balade pas
sur les plateaux télé faire du rap et
que vous allez j'allais sortir de cette
affaire
oui parce que cette mesure chapeau
chapeau ça c'est un homme qui s'est fait
opérer de la honte on lui a retiré la
route depuis ressent plus la route quand
il parle quand il marche dans là ça n'a
aucun sens il transpire de la nasse
hellal autre spur de nacelles de vous
dire de la merde il a marqué un triplé
contre son camp ya un proverbe qui dit
avec des coéquipiers comme ça t'as pas
besoin d'adversaires c'est vrai c'est ce
qu'on appelle le coût du képi a pour les
policiers mais moi un tel triplé contre
son camp ça m'a rappelé un peu marlène
schiappa bien sûr est une habituée aux
là on a ça crie dans un stade
[Applaudissements]
aulas rapide stéphane stéphane stéphane
jean tôt plus on ne va quand même pas
osé elle va pas osé frappe de 80 m au
regard des procédures quand je viens de
changer
il est bas ça fait longtemps qu'ils
commandent des matches mais jamais
jamais on allait aussi bas comparés des
poussins avec la shoah vous imaginez la
joueuse que c'est solveig
elle a l'air de rien la honte orient
bercy solveig services techniques sont
technicienne même le csa deep soul qui
ils bavent bras vous
enfin on se quitte avec une dalle
positive la jouer star du fc pisi de
l'ohada regarder ses idoles mais mon
projet le plus récent c'est avec eryl on
a décidé de monter un spectacle où je
vais chanter obsession alors comme je
t'aime celle qu'on connaît love me
tender enduro d'accord celui là mais
n'ira voir ce spectacle à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau doute idées
complexes
[Applaudissements]
la route